the national football league has
remained conspicuously silent in the
face of the coronavirus pandemic
multiple times the league has said it is
closely monitoring the situation i think
we're at a point where the league needs
to say something more than that the
league meetings coming up in 16 days
i don't think anyone who's been paying
even the slightest attention to the
situation believes that those meetings
will go forward they don't need to
happen at the breakers in palm beach
they can be done by video conference
they can be done by teleconference it's
not going to happen
and it feels like everybody realizes
except the league at this point that
it's not going to happen the bigger
question is the draft six weeks from
today and i'm not saying they need to
make any definitive
statement about what they're going to do
with the draft
but they need to say something about it
they need to say what we're doing mark
davis is the only one who has said
anything and it's just what mark davis
said was enough if the league had just
said that
it would be
uh heartening because you just wonder
what the hell are they doing yeah what
are they doing you can't go hide under
your bed here you gotta show leadership
because chris as you aptly said last
hour there are people out there who take
their cues from the institutions that
they patronize and that they follow and
if there's some guy who's in denial in
new jersey about whether or not this is
really a thing and they see the nfl
taking it seriously and they're a huge
nfl fan maybe they start taking it
seriously right so it's about our
institutions showing leadership and i
credit mark davis for breaking the
silence seriously i'm waiting for the
nfl to say something and i'm not saying
pull the plug on the draft but i'm
saying let people know that the plug may
be pulled on the draft let's get people
thinking about this and let's get people
understanding the nfl is taking this
seriously not just plugging its ears and
hoping it all goes away yeah well we
just want yes exactly right you know
again we want the owners meetings
canceled they'll be shocked if that
doesn't happen yes and then yeah you
would want something of a
some sort of statement about the nfl and
their concern for society and yes they
don't have to cancel the draft but
seriously be thinking about having to
make an adjustment i mean to what mark
davis is saying he's spot on i mean it's
32 different nfl cities their fans and
people from those cities are going to
converge on on a on a city already that
has people from all over the world
and all different states in our country
to begin with so now yeah let's mix them
all together and see how many people can
get it so you know i i looked there at
your twitter page you got people there
oh why do they have to make a decision
on that i see people like challenging
you on that
because if you're listening to this
you don't you don't have to make a
decision but the people who are like
saying well why do you have to make it
we know you don't have to make a
decision but you got to start thinking
about it what are you are you not see
this is a problem people on twitter are
you paying attention the experts on this
in this area in this cat are telling
everybody it's going to get much worse
we don't even know how many people are
infected in our country right now
because we don't even have the proper
testing we're way behind as compared to
other countries so you know when the
testing becomes available every expert
i've listened to last night on any news
channel was saying we're going to be
blown away by how many people are going
to test positive and for how how
prevalent this already is in our society
like you have said many times it's here
already it's not like oh you know johnny
over here in this state has it and jimmy
in this state has it no i saw in a
county one mile from where i live spread
through there in wildfire because of one
guy okay and so that's why we got to
start thinking about making adjustments
we got to be ahead of the curve not like
oh no it's way too late and now we're
all infected and let's try to make the
adjustments now so yes you have to start
thinking about changing the draft it
just it's not good for society and i
know they don't have to make a
definitive statement but they're crazy
if they're not starting to sit in the
meeting room and start having these
conversations
and maybe they are but at some point
they got to share those with us they got
to craft a statement they got to come
out and do something to let us know that
they are not asleep at the switch that
they recognize as the rest of us do that
it's a serious problem sometimes you
just want people to acknowledge it's
serious last night president doesn't
address from the oval office to
acknowledge to the world that he
realizes it's serious that's what i'm
looking for and look i i
anybody who thinks this thing is going
to be gone in six weeks isn't paying
attention it ain't going to be gone in
six weeks
uh six weeks is a blink of an eye as it
relates to this pandemic um
hopefully it'll be gone in six months i
i i hope it will be i'd like to think it
will be but six weeks they don't even
think they're gonna have a vaccination
or anything medical for it for six
months so yeah i i don't think that i
you're like yeah you know what
i i'm
i'm not saying it's time to announce
alternative plans for the draft but uh
the more i think about this and maybe
this is just people working through
anger denial bargaining depression and
acceptance because god forbid they don't
have the draft out in front of a hundred
thousand people that we can see how
impressive the las vegas strip looks i i
think that i think the experts already
would tell you six weeks from now isn't
going to be a good time for 100 000
people to exhaust together in las vegas
where would you do it you know just to
have that conversation like i'm like i
know we got to do it somewhere in a
closed area you know i mean i'd still
want to see something somewhat cool and
maybe i know it's going to be intimate
you know can roger goodell be on the top
of the freedom tower and we do it from
there in new york city what's on the top
like what's but what's really essential
right i know right
what do we really need it's a tv show i
know you're right uh it doesn't even
need to be a tv show it doesn't it
doesn't they could we could get text
alerts as to who the picks are but i
they can come up with something that is
a contained safe environment they can
make it look good on tv and people are
still going to watch it in the millions
because ultimately it's about who your
team gets it's not what what the
background looks like we'll be right
back
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports